hey you guys surprise yeah look how
[ __ ] bright it is in here god damn i
don't know
i don't know why how this happened
suddenly it's exactly the same
light lighting yeah i haven't touched
anything that's that camera i don't
understand it
our shit's on it
yeah the um yeah sleepy we went out last
night
yeah and uh didn't get a whole lot of
sleep we had fun though
yeah we had a [ __ ] great time yeah
not crowded we had a little super smash
i like i danced my ass off i literally
my ass is gone today i left it on the
dance floor
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] testosterone
was [ __ ] kicking last night
a weird [ __ ] it was so weird
[Laughter]
don't wear that don't wear that no put
this on no don't wear that
she wanted to go out and she was wearing
you know it says you need some stock and
says no don't
just just bare leggings she's wearing
this little
dress and it's real short you know i
mean it says yeah just like that then
put some sexy shoes on there
let's go to the club like that just i
won't be able to bend over yeah
just you know [ __ ] weird [ __ ] yeah
she didn't wear it though she said i
can't leave your house like that
oh man well i did wear the dress i had
to wear like leggings
it's not the same effect but the sorry
to disappoint you yeah
sorry that's all right it is horrible
yeah he's all over the place yeah the um
so this is our first uh food show yeah
we
literally just decided to do this
yesterday
yeah we were eating we were walking
while we were sitting at red lobster
eat seafood seafood we literally decided
to do this because i said why don't we
because we hadn't watched a new movie
anyway so i said we don't have anything
to talk about for a matinee show
yeah and so many people have asked us to
do a food show because we always end up
talking about food even when we're
talking about like [ __ ] child murders
and stuff like that
and uh you know so we thought it would
be like a good thing to do and like i
said the the cookbook will be done soon
too but so
we can kind of like tie it all in
together i was like thank you zach
my 24 year old as ass had tequila for
the first time the other night
now what were you doing your ass had to
keep
just playing those weird things with the
with
[Music]
like you know what i mean bad boys doing
that [ __ ] man drinking
ass drinking
well i know that's big in a gay scene
you know man that's right but we're
going to astray tonight
[Laughter]
why are you doing this to me zach why
are you coming up with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro
you came up with that [ __ ] he cried
oh my god my insanity produced it uh
yeah that's
that's exactly what it was so yeah like
i said we decided to
you know and so maybe like once or twice
a week instead of doing
a matination we'll do a food show we'll
just like talk about
whatever we feel like talking about and
this this is such a new idea that i did
actually make um
you know little uh thumbnail images for
it but i didn't have a chance to make an
intro yet
yeah so hopefully at some point they
will it will have a nice little intro
like the other shows have
once we get used to these we get
confident with them we'll we'll roll
with them i don't know how regular
they're going to be we'll just see
yeah like i said it's it could be a kind
of thing where
like i said if we don't feel like doing
a matinee or we didn't see a new movie
we want to talk about we'll just like
talk about [ __ ] food instead because
we always end up talking about [ __ ]
food yeah we don't know how long the
show is going to be either it's probably
not going to be long we're winging it
this is what i did today hand me that
day
the tortillas okay this this is what we
decided to talk about this today because
this is what we made
today some tortillas
yeah these are homemade tortillas corn
tortillas
and they've
when you here in the united states i
don't know about in other countries
you can get pre-made corn tortillas yeah
that's a lot of times that's what you're
going to find in a restaurant
too of these pre-made ones but if you go
to mexico man
they'll have that too you know what i
mean but that's kind of like the cheap
way of doing it that's like their
version of that you could say like
eating a taco on a pre-made corn
tortilla is kind of like
having a ham and cheese sandwich on
wonder bread
wonder breads everywhere it's not really
special yeah and you go to the deli
you get some damn deli homemade bread
it's a lot better
it really classes that sandwich up well
that's the deal with these tortillas
a homemade tortilla when done right and
uh versus a a prefabricated tortilla
bad's night and day
the flavor is so much better yeah it's a
much more i mean because i feel like the
corn tortillas you get at the store are
like a little bit
bland yeah they're a little bit bland
you know um
when you're making your own they taste a
lot more like
corn yeah it's a lot stronger corn taste
the texture is better um you can control
the cooking
time you can control the the with
cooking time
and temperature you can control the
texture of a
tortilla when you finish it because you
got to cook it during the
during the during the fabrication of the
tortilla and then you cook it again when
you're making a taco
you could put it on a on on on on a
tortilla like that
but that's not the way you're going to
do it at a takeda
in in say tijuana or anywhere in in
mexico you know i mean they're going to
have it's going to be a big griddle
with them with the carnitas cooking in a
pan
on the sitting on the griddle and then
working with a bunch of tortillas like
that uh putting cheese in them putting
the filling in them
topping them and sending them sending
them out they make a lot of them they
make them very quickly
it's fast food but it's real good though
so making your own tortillas really
kinda it kind of uh uh
really elevates the taco quite a bit all
right
so what you're gonna need
main thing you're gonna need first
is this yeah amanda just asked that do
you guys have a tortilla maker you just
smash them between use the thing called
tortilla press
tortilla press they're right there right
and this is this is a good one
and you can get them from mexico
actually i got this off of amazon i
think
and it's a mexican company that made it
it's called estrella
and it's from mexico and this shit's
cast iron all right
and it all comes apart so if you need to
clean it you know it's got cotter pins
and what you do is you take once you
make that masa let me show you how to
make them
talk about making the masa you're going
to have
i took a small ziploc bag and cut around
the outside of it to have two pieces of
plastic
you put one piece of plastic here and
then you put the little ball of masa
on it and you kind of flatten it out
just a little bit with your hand and
then you put another piece of plastic
and you close this
and then push it and you're going to
want to get the hang of it
to make sure it'll it'll be perfectly
circled it'll be a perfect circle in
here when you open it up
all right if you didn't have that ball
in the center or you didn't have it
right
actually i it this one seems to like it
a little bit up
a little higher center it'll squish it
into a perfect circle
if you if i try to squish it from the
exact center it'll actually
come out the front so you got to find
the sweet spot
and how big the balabasa it has to be
and how far to squish it all right uh
it's it so it takes
it takes some hand work it takes time
you're gonna [ __ ] them up but after
about a
after about a half hour working with it
and cooking them a few times and [ __ ]
some of them
up you'll get better and better at it
what you do is once it opens
it'll be a perfect brown circle inside
two pieces of plastic
you put that on your hand you peel the
top plastic off
and then um what what you do
is this [ __ ] how do i do it i'll flip it
over upside down and then just start
peeling the plastic off the other side
and you'll have
you'll have the tortilla in your hand
and just throw it in a hot pan
non-stick pad or on a griddle
uh you don't really want oil just flat
and it'll kind of bubble up a few you
only cook it like a few minutes medium
heat
you're not trying to get a bunch of
brown marks on it or anything
you cook it on one side you'll see it'll
slightly kind of rise a little bit in
areas
let it dry let it cook 30 seconds to a
minute maybe
then flip it over with a spatula and do
the other side after that's done
you stack them up on a plate and they'll
kind of steam themselves
in this stack and you're working you're
working from a bowl
and on the press and you have to get a
whole little system made
of you go into the tortilla mode
all right tm manufacturing mode
so you you do it on your counter space
and everything
when you make it when you make a batch
of tortillas you know you start
you're gonna make a bunch of them at
once you know like a stack about that
thick
this is what you're looking for this is
the most common one you're going to find
in the united states
evidently you can get this in europe
it's called maseka
and this is the i think this is the
white or the yellow mesecka i forgot
what does it say i think it's just the
white one you don't have your glasses on
yeah yeah this is just the white one
they have a bunch of different ones they
got a yellow one they got a blue one
i haven't tried but they're harder to
find in the united states
you have to order them mango s do you
have to heat up the press no because
you're
you're just flattening them out just
putting them out in the press press is
cold
yeah all right um when you this is
actually cheap
i think this is about three dollars in
mexico it's even cheaper it's like 70
cents
you can make a lot of tortillas with
this and it'll store
dry like this forever all right
that probably lasts a thousand years but
it's ready to go and what it is
it's two cups of this to a cup and a
half of water
mix it in a bowl and then just let it
sit for a second
all right actually let it sit for about
two or three minutes absorb all the
water
once you have that bola masa
take it kind of push it into a big bowl
and you'll be pulling pieces of
of it off and you're making a round ball
a little bit smaller than a ping pong
that's that
ping pong ball a little bit smaller than
a ping pong ball that's what you want
and you're gonna put it in that press
lined in those plastic bags and do it
and you'll get fast you put it in the
pan that's how it's done
any questions but i'll tell you that way
those tortillas are much better than the
pre-made ones much better yeah they are
much better and a lot more nutritious
zach said can we do an episode on
jambalaya sometime yeah yeah we will i
do that
all right see what everybody's doing all
right now see if there's any questions
in here
yeah see hernandez is tom that's a
quality tour teammate yeah that was the
best one man
the best manual one you know they have
big machines that can do it too but i
don't want that
i wanted something you know that that i
could fit in a damn
and they talk about butt chugging yeah
[Laughter]
that's uh yeah so the tacos that we had
today that we made with those
uh tortillas what did you put on there
you put
uh the pork that you had made did you
slow cook that in the hole i'm listening
with
uh [ __ ] mango says he's gonna get one
off amazon
yeah yeah how much was that one i think
it was about thirty dollars
yeah cause it's cast iron yeah it's 35
well if cast iron is always a good
investment because
yeah that's for quality and it lasts
forever i mean we have a cast iron pan
and we do like
everything with that yeah now we're
going to talk about
okay what you were asking me about you
think you were asking about cardio the
pork that you made that you put in the
tacos today yes
it's carnitas did you put it did you
make it in the uh crockpot
uh that one i did yeah yeah you don't
have to do it in a crockpot but
yeah it's it it's a lot easier well yeah
and really what you want is you walk
you want pork butt which is
that's that it's not in the butt
actually it's above the shoulder on the
pork
pork butt that's dumb why do they call
it it's a cheap cut
it's a cheap cut but it's lean all right
it's pretty lean doesn't have a lot of
fat on it
all right and it slow cooks real well it
makes good carnitas
um in in the cookbook we have come which
there's a carnitas recipe there's all
kinds of carnitas recipes
online you know what i mean um
but it's good and so it's pork shoulder
pork shoulder is even cheaper
but it's got a lot of fat in it all
right so
after you slow cooked before you pull
the meat
and get it all mixed up i i would
suggest going there and
take the bone out it's got a bone pull
that bone out and find those big layers
of fat and kind of try to peel them away
with a big spoon
get them out of there first then a lot
of times what i was doing is i was
taking the whole shoulder and taking it
out of the crock pot putting it on a
cutting board so i could get to all that
stuff and throw it throw the bone out
throw the fat off of it kind of go
through it and then just chop
it in big pieces and kind of mix it a
little bit
um don't you you
mexicans don't like carnitas [ __ ]
just kind of
you know shredded down to nothing they
like chunks in there so you want to
leave some chunks of meat and of course
it's already been seasoned and
everything during the slow
cooking process now you just don't pull
that out of it
out of a just don't pull that out of a
crock pot
and put that on a taco you'll get
slapped if you do that by someone
someone will wander by and slap you but
don't do that chop the meat kind of pull
it slightly put it in a big old bowl
get a big frying pan all right get that
sucker hot
and sear it after it's been slow cooked
because you want brown raised kind of
crunchy edges on it
you know that's that's how you want it
yeah it's good like that then
take it and then take it out of there
and [ __ ] put that put it into
in a storage container you it'll store
for a while if it's spiced correctly it
could store for a week
if it's spiced and cooked correctly yeah
it's kind of preserved like
indian food it tastes fresh for a whole
week
especially if you got it in a good like
tupperware type
container get keep the air out of it
but um you're gonna cook it again when
you make the taco
yeah you're gonna have a big old frying
pan and you're gonna have a big wad of
meat
in there cooking getting some brown
edges on it again on medium heat and
then you're going to push it
to the top of the frying pan and then
you're going to throw your tortillas in
there
flip them over warm them up start to get
them crisp put cheese on it
put some meat from the corner of the pan
into it start topping it
what's in there put your put your uh um
your jalapenos on it and you
probably have a little bit of oil
dripping from the
from from the meat cooking in the corner
of the pan you want to move that
tortilla up into that oil man
and pull it back in there mexicans don't
waste oil
they cook everything in the oil that
that meat's coming in it's it's not
they're doing it on a griddle when you
go when you go to a taco restaurant
where they're doing it
it's on a griddle and a lot of the
stuff's kind of
blending you know what i mean you're
cooking the tortilla and the meat that
in the grease that came off the damn
pork
it's efficient it's very efficient well
yeah that's it flavors
and you shouldn't now some places are
going to be running different kinds of
carnitas and different spice profiles
and some of the stuff's
all pastor which is almost kind of like
a rotisserie like a rotisserie
no what's that stuff called it's like
the uh
it's like that greek yeah yeah yeah
what's that stuff called
[ __ ] man i totally just went out of my
head it's like a rotisserie thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah off our stores
like that yeah
and uh you know some people might be
messing with chicken and stuff
but in general you know mexicans mess
with pork
they like their pig they eat that swine
it really does seem like and we've
talked about this before but netflix has
a pretty good
um series called the taco chronicles and
it
every single episode is about a
different type of taco
and you know kind of the history where
it came like the region that it's from
and how that you know they go and have
people make them and stuff
and um you know 99 of the tacos
had uh pork on them other than the fish
taco but that's not even a mexican
thing really is it that's kind of more
uh and that that's more of a
california mexican i like reading what
they were saying what would you say
the fish taco yeah fish taco
yeah i don't know it might be baja they
would eat that in mexico though too yeah
they'll make any kind of taco
yeah that's another thing it's like
there's a war going on in mexico on the
street
between street tacos
you know yeah and a lot of times some of
this stuff is
family recipes that goes back you know
decades and decades
other guys are kind of yeah they got a
long heritage you know in their little
taco stand
but also they're buying components that
they got get good deals on like today
you might be good might be a good deal
on
a certain kind of pork they're going to
use that or it might be a certain kind
of
might just be a certain kind of deal on
a certain kind of spice profile so
they're going to go that way
it's real flexible there there no two
tacos are the same
everybody's got their own interpretation
of it
okay now here's something else i wanted
to show you
this is like a super common
taco type sauce or a hot sauce cholula
it's not great but it's available pretty
much everywhere
and it's this would be real common
according according to
khan he said that this was everywhere
people used it when you went to a
restaurant this was usually sitting on
the table
okay but it's not real special it's not
real hot either it's kind of salty a
little bit
but you can get it here in the united
states i think for
i think that was even a dollar not even
a dollar yeah
80 cents and i think it's like pretty
much every mexican restaurant i've been
in
to here has that on right so it's just
very standard so so i'm going to bring
in that show you
now these are the ones that i really
prefer if you can get them yeah he likes
these ones all right well i showed this
[ __ ] to connie's because you got that
and said yeah
this is the best one yucateco
yeah okay this is el yukateco
this was the uh this was the the the
he used to have a used to have the name
on it it was like
or some weird [ __ ] like that it was
supposed to be a mayan
plant and this [ __ ] is hot it's habanero
now you this is the one that you
actually have to go to that little
youtube channel they're carrying it now
you can get this you can get this at
walmart now
[ __ ] man yeah he used to have to ride
over to eustis on his cycle
this is the brown one it's brown
it used to be even hotter than this
they've made it mild and
still a lot of people can't eat this i
can't eat it that's for sure
10 years ago when this first showed up
here in the united states it was
twice as hot i was just i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it
[ __ ] is [ __ ] hot you could take a
tablespoon or maybe a teaspoon of this
and probably probably make
about a a gallon and a half of super hot
chili
yeah that's how hot it used to be
and it's got a weird earthy flavor it
tastes like roots
it tastes like dirt but in a good way
that's the best way i can explain it
yeah
it's like roots roots and dirt yeah but
real hot
and it's habanero hot dirt all right
this is a milder one this is the green
one this is a jalapeno
i like this one too i like this it's
it's got a little bit
it's got some heat to it but the flavor
is really good it's got a really good
uh um real good like jalapeno
type flavor you know there's a red one
the red one's good too i don't have it
but the red one's the most common one
the red
uh yucatecal el yukateco but the
very this is this is the one you need to
look for walmart carries it
that's crazy walmart yeah because you
used to have to go we have um you just
have to grow the mexican store
the mexican store about how far is that
12 mile 15. yeah i used to ride on a
bike just to give you guys
just to go get hot sauce because they
didn't they didn't have the brown one
yeah so um talk to you about uh the kind
of cheese
all right because i know that here's the
thing when i was little and when you
were little
in the 70s when you had taco night at
home
you would get like the old el paso
whatever like the hard
shells yeah ground beef with the taco
meat in it like a dorito
yeah it was like a dorito and then uh it
was always like cheddar cheese or like a
mexican cheese blend which is usually
what cheddar and pepper jack or whatever
it is yeah
and you know then you'd put like a
couple tomatoes on there that is really
not
like an authentic taco at all which i
didn't know when i was little
you could you you could you could
probably ask hernandez
he's in there right in the comment
section right now
the california and tech and texas
mexican
or chicano taco traditionally back in
the days we're talking in the 60s and
the 70s and [ __ ]
that was an emergency taco yeah they
were making that [ __ ] out of an
emergency
kind of a crappy taco is better than no
taco right
they were just using the american
ingredients they could get their hands
on it was an emergency
taco it was good but americans didn't
know any better we liked it
yeah i mean they are good but they're
not real they're not really
if you really analyzed what we were
eating back in those days and what a lot
of people are still eating like when you
look at taco bell
all right that's what it is that's
emergency taco
[ __ ] there but it's good but it's
not that's not mexican food all right i
prefer del taco
too bad though tacos we only have one of
those and it's kind of far
from here but that's kind of the same
thing that's not that's not you know
that's not a real taco but anyway it
kind of is it's
kind of it's taco adjacent
[Laughter]
it's mexican-american but um
if khan would probably be fighting he
says no that's not a taco
i think well that's a completely
legitimate viewpoint
yeah well going into brazil with living
in brazil
there were brazilians that swore they
were making hamburgers
swore that they were buying damn
hamburgers or something that is not a
[ __ ] hamburger
another hamburger about that [ __ ] bun
wrong everything [ __ ] wrong
they catch up wrong just that's not a
[ __ ] hamburger
it's you know you know what a hamburger
bun is like right when i was there
brazilians didn't have hamburger buds
they ate
the thing on basically what we would
call like a bisquick biscuit
it was like that it was that was the
texture so it's almost kind of like a
breakfast
yeah yeah yeah and then like there's
nothing wrong with that but it's not a
hamburger
and then yeah but the thing is is that
the breakfast sausage one was
bet that would be even a lot better yeah
yeah the bun was terrible
all right and then another thing that
was was bad was the damn
i'm talking about brazilian hamburgers
now this is the old ones they got
[Laughter]
the ketchup was [ __ ] horrible it was
bright red
i don't think there was hardly i don't
think there was any tomato paste in it
it was a tomato like substance and it
was just sugary
it was like sweet as [ __ ] strange yeah
i mean i mean ketchup does have some
sugar in it or brown sugar but it's not
usually all sugar it's supposed to be
like a sweet spicy balance kind of
i brought heinz 57
ketchup back from the united states one
time all right and let my brazilian
friends have
eat it and they were like oh oh yeah
that's much better
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] that you guys are yeah
brazilian got lost in the translation i
guess
it was it was ketchup it was just
brazilian ketchup and they didn't
execute too well anyway uh what i was
talking about is that if you actually
analyzed
an american taco it's kind basically
sloppy joe mix with
more of a [ __ ] yeah that's exactly
what it sloppy joe mix with the with
the more with the more of a mexican
style flavor
profile and spicy all right
even though that's not the way mexicans
would spice it mexicans would
use like cumin and maybe a little bit of
you know something exotic like a little
bit of cinnamon a little bit of cocoa
or something in there yeah you never
can't tell what they're gonna do i've
seen
so many different recipes but uh and it
it wouldn't be red
you know yeah that meat was red yeah
like it had like that orange
greasy like yeah oil that came out of it
you wouldn't see that in mexican
spicy profiles from you know not in
modern times
and then um and they don't use ground
beef no they're in the tacos they
usually like i said
mostly it was pork it was like pulled
pork mostly yeah which is carnitas yeah
carnitas and then um another thing is is
that
the american taco the taco shells
basically deep fried corn tortilla which
which turns it you're talking about
dorito yeah the glorified dorito it's
crisp and
falls apart when you bite it no
that that will not do that it's
basically a real
tortilla it's fried cornbread
that's a good way to describe it it's
flexible
but it can become crisp it's chewier
it tastes like cornbread it doesn't
taste like a
corn chip yeah if you've ever had
cornbread a lot
some people probably in europe have
never even had cornbread
but it's good it's real good um
and then the things that they're putting
on it are things that just mexicans
in mexico wouldn't put on here well yeah
not put cheddar cheese on there that's a
british cheese
yeah that's that's not a thing if they
were a mexican would put
if he wanted a more authentic tacos in
the united states and he couldn't get
the damn cheese that they normally get
they like a white cheese that's mild and
it melts pretty good
all right the closest thing that you'd
be able to get here in the united states
to that would be like partial skim milk
mozzarella yeah
and they'll use that in in they'll use
that in mexico
they'll use that partial skim mozzarella
but the real one is i forgot what it's
called
hernandez knows what it is hernandez
what's that what's that real mexican
cheese that they use
yeah i can't write it's not queso it's
it's
that that's saltine doesn't melt too
well it's that other one
um yeah because i was saying too that
some of the tacos there like some taco
styles i guess you want to call them
that don't actually even have cheese on
them it's just like meat and a little
bit of cilantro and maybe some salsa or
something
yeah that's what louie just said what's
that um basic mexican taco is tacos de
asada
with salsa and a little bit of cilantro
and onions yeah so there's there are a
lot of variations that i don't actually
have any cheese on them
yeah um but if you want cheese on a i
mean we used to put cheddar on it like
back in the old days before we do any
better but
um now it's like if we put cheese on it
we pretty much always put mozzarella
man it's the same queso ranchero i i
yeah with that i i was thinking of it i
remembered it though
i was thinking well i think they got
owaka okay cheese
which might be queso ranchero it might
be the same thing i don't know but i
think i think it was called oaka
yeah another thing that's kind of more
an american thing is putting sour cream
on the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah mexicans wouldn't put
that on there they'd be like what the
[ __ ] is that sour cream's yiddish
correctly i mean i mean but sour cream
is like is good
i mean i'll put it on there it's good it
just doesn't belong on anything mexican
we made uh what what did you make the
other day you made um
[ __ ] man yeah awake occasionally that's
what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think i think o'laka is the the
more common one i think but
[ __ ] i'm not in mexico what do i know
it's just that's one that comes up a lot
with when i'm reading and i'm looking as
a
waka you can't get it you can get it
here
but i'd have to go down to the mexican
store to get it
yeah like i said we have one not too
long not too far away from here
yeah it's in eustis and that's where the
straight-up mexicans go the dudes that
come here to work
that's their shop they got a dab shop
and a little restaurant right there
they're making their own turkeys we've
eaten in that restaurant too haven't we
yeah the background is pretty good yeah
you can buy homemade tortillas like that
to sell them in a big
uh what do you call it a tinfoil
they'll have them in a cooler i'll keep
them warm in the cooler
and have fresh vegetable fresh fruit
mexican soft drinks like mexican
coca-cola and mexican coca-cola is much
better
yeah than american or european coca-cola
all their soft drinks are much better
because they use cane sugar yeah instead
of that damn
corns corn syrup that corn syrup is it's
cheaper you can make a lot of stuff
you can make you can and we in in europe
we have a lot of corn syrup so it
reduces the price
but there's just something about
cane sugar in in in all right now here's
the weird thing about it
you can get it it's they call it
throwback yeah
all right you can get it in america but
you gotta you gotta look for it
coca-cola throwback diet you know a 7-up
throwback
dr pepper throwback and that's that's
cane sugar that's
so many people asked for that yeah that
was the way it was when i was a little
kid
that's what we drank and what was funny
man is that
when they first started giving us this
corn syrup one of the things that they
were saying
is it wouldn't make you as fat total
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you will get fat [ __ ] drinking soda
that has corn syrup in it
you'll get a lot fatter on corn syrup
than you would on cane sugar
well i feel like it's more concentrated
yeah yeah well there's something about
the way your metabolism reacts to it
and that i thought about it i was
working with this old dude thinking
i forgot his name [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was 90 years old and they still hadn't
[ __ ] working
all right he didn't want to go home you
could fire him and he still could show
up to work
and he would talk your [ __ ] ear off
and he's going
yeah drink say jimmy was his name them
drink those drinks
just not as good as they when they went
over to that corn syrup yeah
i told them i told them you're gonna get
fat
and they all got fat
[Laughter]
back in the depression we would drink
whole cases of soda
and that cane sugar you could metabolize
it you wouldn't get fat
but you get fat off that corn syrup and
it was so good and i
know and i was thinking about it as i
could kind of remember
them you know what i mean i could
remember
what the [ __ ] damn race car yeah it
sounded like a race car
yeah the uh i remembered it you know
what i mean but i couldn't quite
i remember drinking it that it was
different but i couldn't quite
recall exactly the way it tasted and he
was trying to tell me it was like
smoother and creamier and it was
it was not as sweet but it was just
better and then
it had some mexican mexican coca-cola
and i was like oh yeah yeah that's a lot
better and then i [ __ ] found it in
the [ __ ]
throwback yeah because like i said i
think that that's why because they knew
that so many people were kind of going
around and getting mexican coca-cola
you know from little mexican grocery
stores and so
there was a demand for that so they
decided to do it drink it it lights up
the whole inside of your mouth
it has a totally different reaction
party in your mouth yeah well you know
what i'm saying it's like it's like
activating weird taste buds and sensory
stuff inside your cheeks and everything
um when you drink the uh
and it kind of tastes slightly numbing
almost kind of like a little bit of
novocaine or something in it
uh you remember that yeah kind of knew
what i'm talking about it's almost kind
of like your mouth get coated i didn't
drink a lot of soda as a kid i wasn't a
fan
and then and then um when you're
drinking the the modern [ __ ] with that
corn syrup in there
it's super sweet it's all at the front
of your tongue
that's where the sweetness is it's not
in your all around in your mouth
it's like a narrow band sweet yeah
you know what i mean and and it can be
kind of obnoxious
uh [ __ ] the
cane sugar is like broadband analog it's
like the difference between
cd and [ __ ] record and
phonograph record which if you guys have
never heard of damn
record on a good record player is a lot
better than the cd a lot better
well there's a lot well because the cd
the sound is compressed it's compressed
right
so you don't have that broad band of uh
of sound so
the sound has a lot more depth to it
that that my favorite album which is
first last and always it sounds okay on
cd
on record it sounded much better yeah
and they never really made
it was a lot more resonant and things
could you could
you could hear the lyrics a lot better
and the guitars sounded a lot better
and there'd be like resonant frequencies
coming happening in between
the the guitars and certain certain
other instruments it was reflecting just
badass
that but when they they recorded that
thing for for vinyl and then when they
went over to
when they converted it to [ __ ] cd it
didn't quite
yeah they have to like squish it down
yeah yeah yeah it didn't really quite
make the time so it loses some
yeah you know it's it's kind of like
it's kind of like when you take a a
really like high resolution photo that
was like a tiff and you have to like
compress it down to a jpeg like you lose
a bunch of um
information louis said uh tacos de
lingua
are also very good that's tongue is it
yeah yeah i thought it was
yeah they talked about that on the um on
the show as well yeah
louie also said that mexican cook also
comes in glass which gives it a better
footage
yeah yeah that way you're not dealing
with the down plastics and stuff
mango said we cook pork and cola over in
the uk i that's kind of they do that a
lot here too
um you do that in korea yeah you can you
can put like coke or whatever
in the uh in with your roast or whatever
like in your uh
cooker yeah i mean anything like that
will because they'll do it in orange
juice too right
yeah because that's like that's almost
like a cuban yeah because it's got
acids yeah like citrus they'll use like
like a bitter orange or something like
that that's moyo yeah
yeah um but koreans will take thinly
sliced
beef you know when they're making
bulgogi
they'll take a frozen piece of beef and
with a real sharp
knife or on a meat slicer they'll shave
off
frozen slivers of beef
real thin and then they'll take all that
and they'll uh
um marinate it in
sesame seeds sesame seed oil and
coca-cola
and a little bit of brown sugar it's
it's good real good
and garlic yeah yeah and then they
drain it drain it and then barbecue it
it's good cannot the hunter says if i
don't have coke for carnitas i use sweet
and sour sauce
i don't notice a difference huh yeah i
guess that worked
yeah anything i know it sounds weird
like at first blush but when you
actually do it
you know like i said a lot of people
been cooking in [ __ ]
cola for a long time yeah can we um
this isn't exactly taco related but it
is kind of food related
can we tell the story about the
mcdonald's drive through last night
so as usual like every time we go out on
saturday night and you know
we get drunk and dance and stuff and we
were having a really good time
and then of course we're always just
kind of like man i want mcdonald's on
the way home because
you know mcdonald's is right around the
corner it's open 24 hours so it's always
like very tempting
so we go to the mcdonald's through
and i'm pissed because now i mean i
understand why they do it but they don't
have
i don't think they have any chicken
sandwiches no fish
no breakfast pretty much all they had
was like burgers they have like quarter
pounders big macs
you know just beef stuff so i was like
okay whatever i'll just get like a
quarter pounder so we're going through
the drive-thru it was really crowded i
guess because it was like a saturday
night and everybody had the same idea
yeah we were pretty loaded to it we kind
of yeah so um so we get approached by
that's not a good way to put it
that's not a good way to put it no
that's not because that's not exactly
what happened yeah he didn't really
approach
it was kind of like we're going through
that we're going through the
drive-through and i'm coming up on that
damn window and there's just this dude
standing there
on on the curb in the drive-through
looking just [ __ ] dumb
or maybe for lauren
he's big dude about six feet tall you
know i rolled down the window says
what's up with you
no i said you selling some ass yeah
that's right that sounds
nasty no
that's right that's the break sells the
mass and he goes no
they won't let me go they won't let me
order and i was like what and they said
i can't go through the drive through on
foot
yes and then it's locked and i was like
oh man that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they won't let you
walk yeah i'm trying to get something to
eat
and i said get in the back seat
thanks so he gets in the back seat can't
get them
back to me
we're going through the thing that says
order and then you already said yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so he uh i order and then he orders and
we go through it like that and i said do
you like big titties she got some big
ones
show them your titties and she goes i
ain't shy
like that 16.
yeah i didn't know we didn't know he was
just standing there looking lost he's
like they won't let me order figured
because
one six two he didn't look like a little
boy he looked like a [ __ ]
huge man it's just so so funny yeah i
was just like get in the car
we took him he was in the back seat and
we took him to the drive-through and we
just like pulled forward he paid
and then like we got to them we picked
up all our food and uh he's like yeah my
little friends are over there so he
got yeah yeah he ordered for them too
yeah
yeah
he's like thanks man thanks i feel sorry
for them because i didn't see the other
ones they were
they were waiting for them over there
like in the front and they would have
had the bmx bikes and [ __ ]
yeah yeah well that's the thing it's
like they won't let you go in the place
in well they don't well actually even
before kovid they wouldn't let you go in
after midnight after 2 a.m whatever it
was and i think it was like 3 or 3 30 in
the morning
oh thank you zach they're selling
chicken sandwiches at mcdee's now total
rip off of chick-fil-a and so good had
two in the last day they
they actually are the mcdonald's ones
are good yeah i'll tell you what they
had at mcdonald's
what they introduced but they don't have
it anymore at least not not on the night
menu
the double filet of fish yeah they have
it you just can't get it after midnight
yeah that's the way that sandwich always
should have been it should have had two
fish patties on it
well yeah it's got a lot of it got
because then the ratio
the fish and the tartar sauce is correct
that that sandwich makes so much more
sense
when it's got two patties on it i still
haven't got one you got one the other
day and i was
well we were at mannequins and we were
like oh we'll get mcdonald's on the way
home i'm gonna get one of those double
fish sandwiches but they're like yeah we
know we don't have fish sandwiches or
chicken sandwiches
or they didn't have any [ __ ]
breakfast sandwiches either i don't
think
i was looking at the menu last night
because for a while that in the middle
of the night they did have a couple of
breakfast things like you could get like
an egg mcmuffin
and a hash brown or whatever but they
didn't have like pancakes and [ __ ] like
that
but i think last night all that i saw
all they had was like the beef burgers
pretty sure they're like quarter
pounders and big macs and stuff
yeah i don't even think they had any
chicken sandwiches which sucks because i
like that crispy chicken when they do
too like with the the club with all the
tomatoes and [ __ ] on it lisa's imagine
if
[ __ ] jenny had flashed him kidding
i was feeling good man my [ __ ]
hormones were [ __ ] pumping
i'd have been all for it i was like yeah
one of the things i found out is that
when you when you're
i've got to watch myself yeah you do
you're going to get in trouble i got to
watch myself
because because
when you have like [ __ ]
the testosterone of like two 15 year
olds [ __ ] going through your veins
women look unreasonably good-looking
it's weird man yeah he just had an
injection before just when the show
started before the show started yeah
cause i broke i break it up into two
one every three and a half days yeah so
it's not all with one big [ __ ] wallet
there isn't there's many spikes in it
i'm trying to get it nice and even man
you were even like dancing and
everything last night yeah yeah
yeah hadn't done that a long time yeah
it was a fun night actually
yeah it's just start it's here's the
thing though guys i
i was telling jenny i said
this feels [ __ ] really good but i
really think this is only about
half of what i need i think the dose is
about i think the dose needs to be
doubled
i think well like i said next might be
it has to gel it might
take almost six weeks yeah next time you
go and you get your blood work done and
they'll be able to reassess like what
the level is and then
you can ask them i think i think it
needs to be doubled
man if you're like this now it's like if
it was double i don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen i could take another
i don't know what's going to happen at
that point i could always see he'd just
be he's
i can always just inject it and see what
happens i would have to like sort of
beat you off of the bat all the time
all the time all right i walked into
that one didn't
you walk right into that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you walk into that [ __ ] ass first i'm
just saying
she said back it up [ __ ] up
i'm telling you i'm just like it's
[ __ ] bad [ __ ]
you know i got an extra stash
yeah i got an extra stash of it yeah i
could [ __ ] bump
bump up that dose [ __ ] twice
and see what that does yeah see
yeah but see the thing is though is is
that they told me about six weeks to
stabilize it
so we'll wait we'll wait until after the
six weeks is lapsed like maybe i'll do
that week eight
yeah yeah i mean if i don't like the
results we're out week eight maybe i'll
double it and see what happens
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that shouldn't be bad
ass
dario runs was late so he said a dose of
what
testosterone testosterone i'm gonna
double that [ __ ] tammy said jenny's
gonna have to lock him out of the
bedroom
i'm not ever gonna get any sleep
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] weird man cause i'll be
[ __ ] grabbing going come here come
here
i'm here i can't really do anything
about it it's just in my mind
it's like what nothing
it's like it's like it's like it goes
away it's a roller coaster for sure
[Laughter]
it just depends it depends on what the
hell happened
oh my god hormones are [ __ ] powerful
drugs man
[Laughter]
i'm a true believer now yeah it really
has uh
like a large has a large effect on it
yeah yeah it's actually kind of
hilarious well what's funny is that also
i start talking about all these new
projects that i want to do
see that's good because it's giving you
like your positivity yeah you start
getting real mentally positive
yeah i mean that's one of the main
things that i've noticed yeah and then
you wanted to like
yeah a lot better yeah i can see why
they're giving this to these dudes that
are [ __ ] coming out of special forces
in delta
because you're coming out of a high
energy left level area and when they
when they start to retire or they or
they get medically retired or they're
just [ __ ] worn out
and they [ __ ] send them home for a
while they'd come down and had these big
hormonal crashes and go through all this
depression and [ __ ] and some of them
commit suicide
yeah but they give them this and they
keep them up there and it
[ __ ] they stay good well because it
makes you feel like you have a purpose
yeah like you want to do stuff you feel
like enthusiastic yeah right
about [ __ ] right louis said tom's going
to be knocking on the door without using
his hand
[Laughter]
it's just [ __ ] funny man i was still
laughing about that [ __ ] kid in the
[ __ ] mcdonald's drive through last
night
no but had i known what i know now i've
gone on this [ __ ] at 40.
yeah yeah oh well just for just just for
the skin detector
i know it's like that's what i kept
saying we were at the bar last night
talking to lee the bartender
because we haven't seen him in a while
yeah and i was like yeah look his skin
feels like a baby's butt yeah
[Laughter]
all right you have any more that you
would like to add about tacos
or tortillas no we covered it or
anything anybody have any questions over
any of this [ __ ]
yeah this is actually this is kind of i
think we're gonna like doing this series
it seems a lot of fun
and you know and we can always like
revisit topics too if we didn't
like cover everything that we had we had
um we had a small crowd but it's okay
the
show will be posted up you know we had
30 watching
uh if you if you guys uh enjoyed the
show go ahead and
or you know drop it in the comment
section i'd like to see you know did you
guys
enjoy the show if you if there's any
ideas you can put that in there too
yeah i mean we'll probably do because i
think your idea that we were talking
about yesterday
was that we were going to do like kind
of general stuff at first
like we'll do a show about like you know
indian or maybe not that general but
like curries or you know what i mean
but then like as the show goes on um
you know we can do like more specific
dishes oh thanks again zach
in general what is both of your favorite
food or dish
oh man come on that's really hard
because honestly i'll eat pretty much
anything
um [ __ ] if i had to choose
one cuisine yeah to eat your whole rest
of your life
yeah hard to say i don't know it's a
three-way tie
indian italian seafood is that a really
a cuisine
i guess i don't know it's too hard and
actually if i had to pick a favorite
dish okay some of my favorite dishes
that you make
yeah um first thing i think of
uh chicken paprikash which we haven't
made in a while yeah i gotta make that
man that's good i'm gonna get that
hungarian paprika though you can get it
at publix
well i got it at publix before i don't
know if they carry it now it's not in
the same place you have to like look
down at the end of the aisle they put it
in a weird spot
um but yeah that it's yeah it does taste
different
um but yeah so that's probably one of my
favorite things that you make
also another thing you haven't made in a
while too is that uh
[ __ ] man what's that thai curry that you
make sometimes with like the peanut
butter
oh yeah the seitay type oh man yeah i've
made that in a while god damn that [ __ ]
is so good i'm sure it's like super
fattening it's real [ __ ]
high gallery god damn it it's so funny
and it's hard for me to get it right you
guys love it but i'm always
kind of not satisfied with it there's
always something wrong with it
from my point of view it's either too
thick or it's too thin or it didn't
really
gel real well with the the type of
noodles that i used there's you know
that's kind of i think i gotta go i
gotta get back off into that i gotta
taste some
some good i gotta taste i gotta taste
that dish
done right a couple times we need to go
to a decent restaurant and have there's
a bunch of thai restaurants around here
right i won't buy the water i gotta be
able to absorb the debt
you see some of this [ __ ] you can't do
just the recipes alone
you got to taste somebody else's cooking
yeah because you're not really sure what
it's supposed to taste like right
and you gotta you gotta and you want a
variety of a couple different cooks
doing that dish
that way you can kind of good cooks that
way you can kind of absorb
the spirit behind that dish yeah
you know what i mean there's a certain
spirit behind it and uh
i don't quite have the spirit of seytae
yet
well we don't make it that often we
don't have it that often and don't make
it that often
and and we need to go buy some of it and
have it so i can
become one with that for a while and
then i'll be able to reproduce that
i really do like that curry theme it's
that it's the the thai curry paste i
think it's the one the yellow can right
the masaman whatever it's called uh that
curry paste
and then there's like a you know
generous amount of peanut butter
and it's there's potatoes in it too
right i think there's chunks of like
potatoes like red potatoes
and um i don't know like the few times
you've made it it was
one time you made it and it was so good
that i think i ate four bowls
like not at one sitting i had like two
bowls and then like a couple hours later
i had two more bowls
because it was like so good i couldn't
stop eating it
yeah got mango and he's ordering that
that tortilla press
yeah i mean if i was in england i
wouldn't even [ __ ] around man i'd get
that mossa masaka and get that press
right there
and uh just for pennies you can make the
best tortillas
you're gonna [ __ ] some of them up all
right but that's just this is part of
the learning curve but that's somewhat
always yeah but somebody said earlier it
might have been tammy or amanda i can't
remember but they said yes just like
making pancakes and waffles always mess
up the first one or two
thank you very much hayden great show
love mexican food
i do too man yeah this was it was really
hard we weren't sure
because i because i kept asking him this
morning i was like what kind of food do
you want to talk about today and he's
like oh man i don't know
and um i made mexican and then you made
tacos like a couple like an hour or two
ago and he's like okay well
we'll just talk about tacos and making
tortillas and [ __ ] like that because
like that's that's the show
and yeah and plus um that's gonna be in
the cookbook as well
right um yeah the cookbook is gonna be
done
pretty soon i have one i'm doing the
drinks and dessert section which is the
last section and we got to do a photo
shoot because
i got she's going to layer me into on a
couple of the pages and i'm going to put
pookie and beijing in there yeah
and then uh with little chefs outside
that um that cookbook is
uh design first it's gonna be hardcover
so it's gonna be good
real good quality yeah i really wanted
it to be not gonna cost that much maybe
30 bucks
i think yeah i have to see i'm not sure
because i
initially was thought the page count was
going to be 200 but now i think it's
going to be like 160 pages i don't know
so
um so i'm not sure like what the cost
like what our cost is going to be i
think it's like 22
for us yeah so then you'd like you have
to have a markup or something and then
um
uh what i was going to say oh [ __ ] what
was i talking about
the cookbook yeah i was getting sleepy
too
the uh yeah i forgot what i was talking
about
you were talking about the cookbook yeah
but before that um
something before the cookbook the reason
why i mentioned um
oh it was uh it's about making tortillas
yeah yeah if i was in england i would
just i'd get that in a second and then
get a press
and you're gonna [ __ ] up some of them
but just you know
make some tortillas another thing that i
learned today is that sometimes when you
take the when you take the
the the the raw tortilla
it's in your hand it's come out of the
press and you've taken it off the
plastic sheets
which that's going to take you a little
while to get used to that you can go
online and see videos of people doing
that to kind of
get an idea of how much space you're
going to need for this process
and how you're going to have to change
one from one hand to the other and
peel plastic off of it and when it's in
your hand some people will just kind of
like
slam dunk it into the into the hot pan
some people will kind of just
put lay the corner off and walk it off
walk there walk it off their fingers
like doing that all this stuff okay well
of course you will because
now because i can't so that's it
when you got an enough testosterone in
your bloodstream
like that you know [ __ ] and put it
right in there like that you know
well i did that one time and it folded
over on itself
oh see it cooked for a second that was
and i was trying to flip it back
i scooped it back out of there with the
spatula and rolled it back into a ball
and repressed it it worked fine
okay it worked like yeah so don't worry
about it
[ __ ] it up drop it in the pan it can
cook for a few seconds it can be half
done
you can pull it back out of there and
put it right back into a ball press it
and put it in there and it didn't make a
difference yeah they're kind of
forgiving yeah it's forgiving
yeah so uh
you know that'll take you down your um
your taco
[ __ ] journey your taco journey taco
journey yeah for all your taco needs
yeah now goya which is not a mexican
company it's a spanish company they'll
make chorizo
i got cherries and it's vacuum packed in
a [ __ ]
bat and a plastic pack
they're little and they're little
sausages and i think there's
six of them or five of them in there and
it wasn't expensive
it was only like two dollars
i took that put it on a cutting board
with it with a kitchen knife and kind of
minced it into little chops
put that in into a frying pan with a
little bit of um
like mexican profile seasonings like
cumin
and some salt actually no i didn't use
salt it was already salt enough just
cumin
and just kind of tossed it in it in its
own oil and used that
for taco meat it was pretty good
all right i don't think you had it i
don't think so either
yeah it was pretty good you didn't have
it for some reason
i think i think i fed you something else
you had something else maybe i think you
had uh
fish taco oh okay yeah here's another
thing that i found out
we like fish tacos
it's easier though if you get some
[ __ ] good quality fish sticks and use
that as a taco filling yeah we cheat
yeah and that tortilla right there
[Laughter]
bake it and then once they're done bacon
[ __ ] take all those fish sticks and
put them up on a plate
and then when you're making tacos when
it's come time to do it you put the
tortilla in there the cheese
throw a fish stick in there with it heat
it up throw it back on the center of the
taco start topping it
yeah yeah put some salsa a little bit
yeah sauce and everything lime juice
lemon juice or whatever
for some people who don't know what
we're talking about haven't seen the
photographs mexican tacos are not folded
over you fold them when you eat them
well yeah just grab to be a mess yeah
they're round you pick them up and
they're kind of flexible
even if they're crunchy they're slightly
flexible you know the
the shell will flex and kind of crunch
at the same time but it won't shatter
and fall apart like some american
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know that damn deep
fried
yeah never to figure out how to eat it
without just yeah
after a while like when i was a kid i
said you know what just give me the
shell and i'll just break it up
and then i'll just put all this i'll
make a salad yeah talk this out
because there was like no point in like
trying to eat it because it would just
go
yeah it'd just fall apart zach asked
what was the grossest thing you've ever
eaten
first of all you never he asked me what
the best thing what would i eat
my choice oh okay yeah you did and i
never did answer them if i could only
eat one thing for the rest of my life
it would be chilled boiled shrimp
yeah you know cajun style with some good
zadaran seasoning
boiled in zadoran seasoning with uh my
own homemade cocktail sauce mm-hmm
yep that's [ __ ] pure protein
pure protein i mean i love seafood yeah
i know that i know
seafood seems like it's a little bit
divisive like some people like really
really don't like it but
i don't know i love [ __ ] soup i could
live off of crab legs
yeah i probably could too actually i
could live off it
yeah when it [ __ ] man when i went to red
lobster when i went to red lobster
yesterday i even got i got the little
the
the broiled shrimp skewers and like a
little half lobster tail
yeah and a little bit of broiled salmon
yeah or grilled salmon i guess it was
that was delicious but darius if you get
the colombian chorizo it's the best
okay i haven't seen the colombian one
yeah okay stop propagating uses wax
paper with the tour
that that works too but i found just
taking um the ziploc bag
and cutting cutting around the edges of
it it'll make two
squares and that ziploc bag
can be reused because it'll wash yeah
and it just comes off there too
yeah amanda said i always use either
halibut or sea bass for my fish tacos
yeah that'd be good too yeah that would
be good yeah um
i can't think of like the grossest thing
i've ever eaten i probably figured you
would you would say that uh
that boudin stuff that you got like that
ball of yeah boudin
organ meat or whatever yeah i don't i
can't really think of anything that i
ever ate that was
so disgusting that i just like spit it
out
man i can't i really can't think of
anything boo damn ball
the boo damn ball didn't taste all that
bad
it was just rotten yeah i threw it up
so it didn't really you know i mean i
regretted eating the buddha
boo damn ball it was a ball
and i just called it it said put their
hand on there
and i said that's boo that i never had
boudin you know
and i said let me get that boo damn ball
and no
was it like a horror movie where they
warned you or are you sure you want that
they were just like oh okay
so let me get let me get let me get let
me get that boo damn ball
they give me the boo damn ball that's
probably armadillo meat in there yeah
[Laughter]
spoiled that's pretty that's that's
[ __ ] horrifying it's yeah sucking
this shit's a mess
kidneys in it and livers in it and stuff
you know british people would love that
[ __ ]
they would probably love it yeah like
all those internal organs and [ __ ]
yeah it's well i feel like europeans and
it's admirable that they use like a lot
of the organ meats and stuff because
every here i feel like a lot of it goes
to waste because a lot of people don't
like it um they use it for other
applications like pet food and stuff
yeah pet food
um but yeah like over there
i just feel like people are eating like
blood sausage like black pudding like
for breakfast and stuff and i'm just
like man i can't
i can't face that that early in the
morning another weird thing i don't know
how common this is
but another weird thing was people would
eat for breakfast
like canned spaghetti essentially like
chef boyar if not even chef boyardee
quality it was like more like
franco-american canned spaghetti
on toast yeah terrible and i'm like why
why would you want to ruin a perfectly
good piece of toast that way
like making it all [ __ ] doggy and
[ __ ] i don't and i'm not a snob i don't
have a thing about canned spaghetti i'll
eat some chef boyardee i don't get
you know but uh why would i put it on
toast is so nice and crispy
poverty [ __ ] making you a hell of a
[ __ ] thing i suppose yeah
i mean toast is is nice just with like
some bread some butter on it and you
know maybe some some peanut butter some
cashew butter maybe a little bit of
cinnamon and sugar we know that
in the uk they will eat canned beans for
breakfast and i'm just
that doesn't belong there on that on
that plate yeah i think that is actually
part of a full english they have like
eggs
and it's like yeah it's like baked beans
it just doesn't belong on that dish
i mean baked beans we eat them here but
that's usually that's like a picnic food
yeah like you eat it with like fried
chicken and coleslaw yeah we also modify
that [ __ ]
just nothing so you never eat that
straight out of the can what you do is
you take
a bunch of cans of that all right like
six cans of that
and you pour it into a big bowl and you
mix brown sugar into there
and some ketchup into it and a whole
bunch of french's
mush mustard mushrooms yeah and then a
whole bunch of
diced up dill pickles all right you dice
them up
mix it up in there put it in a put it in
a glass pan
and rebake it yeah that's not my grandma
yeah
like no problem 375 maybe maybe 425 i'll
probably bring it up 425
until it cooks in towards towards the
center and all that stuff it'll it'll
bubble
and all that [ __ ] will kind of condense
down into a nice thick kind of
like a candied baked beans be like a
boston big bean
kind of candy it's good with the little
dill pickles in it and everything
you don't taste those that much but you
just kind of give a little
yeah like i feel like the mustard really
that's kind of more like a real
summer yeah picnic kind of food like you
bring it to a picnic like if you're
having like fried chicken and burgers
and [ __ ] like that
yeah mashed potatoes coleslaw all that
kind of stuff that would all go together
um it's just it's it's really weird to
me how
some foods are like acceptable as
breakfast foods and some things are not
acceptable as breakfast foods even
though whatever food is food
yeah i guess since we do eat we bre bake
beans for breakfast here too she's in
australia
so um yeah it's just uh
i feel your pain
[Laughter]
being connected with [ __ ] old-school
british culinary
influences i'm saying you know
there are some fantastic [ __ ] british
cooks now you know [ __ ]
gordon ramsay my [ __ ] hero man is
like my idol all right
in terms of culinary [ __ ] you know uh
he's british
[ __ ] actually he's [ __ ] scottish
he's got it he's got us yeah but he's
all
you know all in the uk and i think he's
recognized there in england too
as being one of the greats and he
corrected a lot of that [ __ ] and
a lot of the [ __ ] that the british
people do is they do it for the same
reasons
we did certain things in the south and
that was the influence of poverty
yeah is that where we're you'll come up
with some weird
culinary ideas that don't work but you
think they work
because you grew up with them but the
thing is is that
your ancestors were poor and that's what
that's the only thing they had
if they had other options that wouldn't
have come out
now there are some people that were poor
for a long time but were in a land of
more kind of like plenty and
a land of plenty so they had good
taste buds and that's what we're talking
about with southern food and soul food
okay almost everything
from the southern and soul flavor
profiles it all tastes good
and that and as a testament there's uh
mama cherie opened up a soul food
restaurant in england and it was like
their number one restaurant for a long
time and it was just regular soul food
southern type food well it was good yeah
that and actually um yeah didn't gordon
he did a um
he did a kitchen nightmares on it
although that was the only
show that i ever saw but it was one of
the british ones yeah that was the only
show that i ever saw him do where he
where he's like well the food's not
really the problem
[Laughter]
she knew what she was doing yeah the
and why that happened is because the
south
was low income traditionally you had a
lot of low-income people
but it had a lot of food it was an
agricultural powerhouse
so they had food then maybe they
couldn't afford the best cuts
of pork but there were there was pork so
they knew what to do with you know other
stuff
maybe uh vegetables and fruit and
vegetables were
festive vegetables they were just around
uh maybe you didn't get the choices cut
of that vegetable like collard greens
are the things that just come off of
these things you know what i mean and
turnip greens are the things that
sprouting up off the top of a turnip
normally you'd throw that away but a
southerner would keep that
yeah and turn that into like a good side
dish
well yeah because if you spice it right
it's actually pretty good there are some
countries like
north korea that are so [ __ ] poor and
they'll eat all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
because they're poor but there's nothing
to work with
yeah that's a totally different
situation england was kind of like that
it was very uh
uh most of it was very uh urban
so their poor people were in like brick
dumbbell tenements a lot of times in
brick apartments and they didn't have
anything really to work with
just some canned food well how much you
can do with that i kind of feel like
that's what happened here like in
mid-century like post-war type of stuff
where everything was like canned and
boxed yeah
everybody was really getting into like
the convenience you know what i mean
and it's like you know let's take little
cans of vienna sausages and you know
pour it on [ __ ]
yeah you know [ __ ] like that we're
making casseroles with [ __ ]
canned cream of mushroom soup and all
that kind of crap
yeah and that's not the same situation
that was in the south
poor people in the south are kind of
like poor people in the countryside of
mexico
yeah they don't have a lot of money but
they got a garden in the back of the
house yeah
you know so they're dealing with fresh
ingredients they eat pretty good
they're selling a lot of it and then
some of their keeping they're trading
you know and i as a kid i remember that
the people of my grandparents age they
were they were all like the
the the people that survived the
depression they all had little gardens
out behind their [ __ ] houses
yeah you know watermelons uh corn um
okra tomatoes yeah we just tomatoes will
grow pretty much anywhere in florida we
used to grow tomatoes in the backyard
and
um pumpkins too yeah and we tried to
grow some watermelons but only a couple
of them came out and it was just second
nature to them they didn't even think
about it they'd go out and start playing
[ __ ]
and i think it was just because they
grew up in the in the depression so
the people who were planting were mostly
the ones who survived
yeah so they were kind of natural
selection if you made it through that
then it was because you were the person
that
planted things and then it was
reinforced in you that it was oh
why would you not want free food yeah
it's right there
it's right there so we had an orange
tree in the backyard too
like my grandmother's house but the
oranges were a little bit i guess the
tree was real old so the oranges that
started going a little sour
but you could still make lemonade with
them you could still make marinades with
them you just couldn't like just eat
them right off the tree
you know what i mean another thing about
southerners uh was
uh the fishing all right [ __ ]
lots and lots of catfish yeah i don't
think a northerner probably would have
eaten a catfish
if they'd seen it i mean it's just
[ __ ] that's not the kind of fish that
you would you would think would
be edible when you see it it's ugly it's
like a slimy it doesn't have any scales
on it it's got skin
it's got big old [ __ ] whiskers
it's got poison fins um
you cut the head off and the head will
be alive for about three days
on the bank just like
just all happening yeah everybody yeah
it's like
yeah and it's on the bench unsettling
it's not even in the water and it's
[ __ ] the head's still alive
so and there and they're hard to clean
you got to [ __ ] skin them
with a pair of pliers pull the skin off
of them
um but it's a delicious fish it's kind
of like an eel
you know the texture and the flavor of
catfish is like
eel it's a primitive fish
and i think a northerner would have
turned their nose up on it but they got
huge
[ __ ] huge all right yeah i've seen
some scary big catfish
and those are the little ones they could
like swallow a
[ __ ] child yeah well i think i think
i think in
ancient times they were big enough to
swallow a man it's just that
oh i don't doubt it it's that they fish
them though yeah so they don't ever get
that
big i mean they still even [ __ ]
jeremy wade has caught some like scary
big ones yeah it looks like they could
kill you
yeah and who knows how old that fish was
maybe only 50 years
well how big are they when they're 80
years yeah you know how big are they
when they're 120
because a lot of those things don't
really seem to die of old ages get so
big they can't get enough food to
survive and they starve
you know like alligators yeah but um
southerners didn't even really fish they
did things called
trotting and they'd run a trot line
which is just
tie a rope around in one tree and then
go
wait out in the water and take the rope
to the other side of the damn
pond and tie it to another tree so it's
about a foot off of down
water and in that rope it's got little
fishing lines with hooks
in the water so it's just a lot of hooks
and you
and you don't even need bait on them
fish will still
bite that hook it's like huh what's this
oh damn it that was really avoidable
catfish will bite them
you do bait them baiting them will
assure that you you will get something
but a lot of southerners discovered that
you just put the bait
you could just put unbaited hooks in the
water and come back at the end of the
day and there'll be three or four fish
on it
see to me i always thought that if you
were in a survival situation and you
could find like a body of water that
would be the easiest
because that is the lowest effort right
to get
meat it's a lot easier than hunting yeah
um you know it's
you just kind of like you let it ride
yep
and you can run like four or five trot
lines across the same pond
yeah and spaced out five feet and just
come back every day and lift them up
lift it up and see if there's any fish
on the hooks there's fish you run out
there
wait out there and get them yeah it's so
easy
it's free food yeah and we used to when
i was a kid we used to catch crabs we
had little crab traps yeah let's go out
there to the river and catch crap yeah
it's just the thing oh
folds put them on the grill yeah and you
might have a fish tied to it a dead fish
tied to it they'll crawl into there to
eat that fish and when you pull the
cage up it closes up and then you rip
the crabs in there
pull the crabs out and then just throw
it back out there get out you try to get
them all
wipe them out
they'll make more but they're little you
throw them back but you know
yeah yeah all right so man we've been
going for an hour and 17. oh [ __ ] hour
and 17 minutes
all right let's see if there's any see i
just see you were worried about it's
like i don't know if i can talk about
food for that long i'm like come on
we end up talking about food on this on
the regular show we're trying to talk
about other [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean yeah
tammy said that she grew up in central
pennsylvania we ate catfish yeah you eat
catfish now
but you probably wouldn't have eaten
catfish back in the late 1800s or 1800s
i don't think they would have maybe
stomp prop says there is a wild meat
restaurant in orlando
i had a sampler with lion and all kinds
of [ __ ] yeah
really i wonder if that's still there i
never heard of it
it's here in orlando i'm gonna have to
look that up now
i mean i don't i don't really want to
eat a lion but you know
[Laughter]
if you uh go back into into history
there's a lot of foods that we eat today
that they didn't eat in the 1800s
one of the weird ones is a tomato they
thought tomatoes were poisonous yeah for
a long time
for a long long time they thought
potatoes were poisonous yeah
i was just gonna say that um there's a
lot of that seafood
people wouldn't eat they thought it was
dangerous although they used to eat a
lot more eel
in europe particularly in england back
in the old days and they don't really do
much of that anymore
well they had weird beliefs that are
kind of forgotten too
they thought up an animal made poison
or venom that it it must be poisonous so
don't eat that
which makes me think that they might not
want to eat a cat catfish in the 1800s
because
they were considered to be poisonous
well yeah you wouldn't want to risk it
you wouldn't want to risk it
because catfish have poisoned spines on
them not a lot of people don't know
about but
i don't think all of them have them but
the ones we had did
yeah and mud cat i mean mud cats [ __ ]
it and that's another thing
they didn't really differentiate between
catfish and mud cat and a mud cat is
a certain breed of catfish that's kind
of shorter and fatter
and kind of more rounder and
they taste terrible terrible
they just taste like mud yeah mud
hence the name mud mud
throw them back a lot some people kill
them they catch them and they go oh it's
a mud cat and they kill it
[ __ ] that to try to wipe them out yeah
because they don't want them in there
they don't want them
competing against catfish but you
just people don't eat them although some
people say some people say oh i eat them
too you know being all manly about it
you know
because it's manly to just eat
disgusting
all right man i need a nap holy crap
it says some uh yeah catfish don't stop
growing i don't think they do
yeah uh it makes me want to taste
caribou i've had caribou caribou is one
of the is the best meat i've ever had i
haven't had it in a long really
yeah caribou's the best i've ever had
it's kind of like beef
but a lot more succulent oh i like the
sound of that
yeah it kind of has a slight tartness
too it's weird
um there's no way to describe it like a
really good
it's like a cross between venison and
beef but venison's
difficult to cook all right it tends to
want to get tough
caribou kind of has the meat that had
kind of had the fibers the size of a
of a cow you know the meat fibers
so you could it could be tender that's
what i'm trying to say
yeah but it kind of has a slight not a
gamey taste to it but it does kind of
taste
it does kind of taste like it like
venison a little bit which slightly
lemony from what i remember
i would probably try that actually it's
good probably get it around here
somewhere
probably buy it yeah that's farm raised
though yeah the one we had was wild
my dad went uh took a flight up to
canada with some guys and they
went on a hunting expedition and shot
several of them
and then cleaned it and [ __ ] flew it
back in the airplane said in the
flipped there in the cessna yeah it was
in the tail
it put the caribou in the plane yeah
well
it was already it was already dressed
you got into stakes and it was just you
know what i mean they had it all up in
the tail
wrapped up it came out where they they
cooked it it was something delicious man
really good so
wild boar also we had these things
called russian boar
in mississippi there's a channel
on youtube called hannah barron and
hannah barron and her dad
she's a cute girl from alabama but it's
the same
ethnic makeup as mississippi you know
because it's the same people
mississippi and alabama used to be the
same state
they all used to be mississippi but um
her dad trap they trap
what we would call russian bore which is
a breed of domestic pig mixed with
russian
i think it was a razorback so it's like
half razor back and half
and half pig um they're not a wild
animal
so they don't apply to game laws it's
considered to be varminting
so you can trap them the way that
they're doing them because it's not a
it's not a native species to mississippi
so it's not protected
it's considered to be domestic
so some of the [ __ ] that you see her
doing don't think you can hunt like that
russian boar is not a not a game animal
right it's it's
it's domestic so they're what they're
doing is what they're doing is they're
baiting them
to go into a round pin and then they
shut the door to the pin go
and just shoot them in the pen yeah they
don't show that part
but it's slaughter it's not hunting but
you can do it with that animal that's
not
that's not a wild animal yeah so it's
it's legal
xanada just said we work with exotic
meat sometimes at my work
alligator alligator andouille or python
rabbit sausage
yeah there's lots of foodies now wanting
weird meats yeah
yeah it's really that's kind of one of
the cool things it's this explosion of
everybody wanting to try all these
different like cuisines and [ __ ] when
i mean when we were growing up it was
very very provincial yeah
i don't recommend alligator i've had a
bunch of it i've had it before i
remember it
dry yeah i remember it being okay but
not really all that
it's like real flaky dry fish
to me almost kind of like verging on dry
chicken
yeah that's kind of what it reminded me
of slight fish flavor
i think i had like i was at the seafood
restaurant when i was younger and i was
i had a platter and it had like
alligator and shark and like some other
stuff on there the shark was pretty good
but i remember the alligator just being
kind of like you said just kind of like
chickeny just kind of dry a little bit
yeah not really worth it i mean i guess
if it's prepared
i've had it i've had it cooked by
supposed masters at all
it always tastes like that janet i said
alligator is okay deep fried well pretty
much everything that might be right
[Laughter]
it's just not it's it's something that
you would eat
if you were hungry yeah and you couldn't
get any hold of anything else
yeah if you're living out in a [ __ ]
swamp or bio and yeah
eat it it's there
they were illegal to hunt in in
louisiana for a long time
because they were just wiping them out
but you could hunt them now
yeah i'm not sure about now uh in
florida
are they still protected in florida i'm
actually not sure i don't know
i think they were for a time i don't
know if they are anymore because i think
the people
get in and out of it well because the
population goes down so much that they
have to like protect them
until the population comes back
mississippi and louisiana have a problem
with a thing with a thing called a
called a nutria or a neutral
yeah some people call it a neutral rat
yeah
and it's a giant it's kind of like a
small cappy bottom
yeah that's what it looks like yeah it's
it's not a rat
but it's a it's it's a rat like creature
it looks like
it looks like a rat and they're not from
here they're from south america or
central america and they just take over
and they eat all the little [ __ ] lily
ponds and [ __ ] and [ __ ] up the
environment for the animals
that belong here and they reproduce in
vast numbers
so um they had a bounty on them they
were paying you
certain about to go out there and kill
them they were just trying to work
because they were just everywhere
trying to wipe them out and um
some some uh some cajuns figured out
that you could eat them
because of course yeah cajun's the late
anyway yeah
there are some there are some neutral
recipes out there
and uh they've gotten it to where it
evidently tastes pretty good
but they're just americans are just kind
of adverse to eating the rat
that's even though it's technically not
really technically not a rat but they're
going to look at that and go that's a
rat
and you know the chinese eat rat all the
time
which that's weird [ __ ] but they do i
mean meats meat yeah i
saw a video of a little little girl
about six years old with a damn
dead rat in her hand and [ __ ] you
know
and her mom's walking her like that and
[ __ ]
the comment was like that that's food
they eat those
you remember like that that newer show
that gordon ramsay has he actually went
to louisiana didn't he and he went on
one of those
nuclear hunts yeah and one of the guys
um his mom
had made like a nutria stew and he
brought it along in a thermos and like
gordon was eating that and he's like man
that's delicious
yeah i don't know if he just said that
for the camera but um
but yeah he said it was really good it's
kind of like squirrel
squirrel but evidently it kind of has a
little bit of a musty flavor to it
you know what i mean maybe they're
living out in the [ __ ] they're living
in the bio
yeah i can see them probably not tasting
all they don't taste that good they
don't think they eat
i mean but like i said if there's so
many of them and you have to wipe them
out
you might as well eat them because like
it just was good
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying you
don't want to waste stuff
yeah all right yeah that's good yeah i'm
getting really really sleepy
yeah like i said we didn't get much
sleep less i don't think we went to
sleep until like 4 30 in the morning or
something
uh but yeah all right so hopefully you
guys have enjoyed this new food show if
you have any recommendations for new
stuff you want to do
like i said i don't know if we'll do
another one of these
in the week it'll just be the same time
as like the matinee one
so it'll either be like a matinee or one
of these like depending on
whatever we feel like talking about that
day but uh yeah you know so
let us know if there's any kind of
cuisine you want to talk about or any
kind of [ __ ]
uh and we will see you guys again
tomorrow thanks everybody for dropping
by and donations and whatnot
and uh we'll see you then bye